it's not that it wasn't a thought or it
hasn't been obviously but it's always we
always are respecting what one another's
doing so for instance like having her
album come out and this stuff and that's
hers Selena Gomez talking Taylor Swift
but sorry guys it does not seem like a
collab is happening any time soon
though we know there's a lot of love
there she was frustrated when I was
frustrated she was sad when I was sad um
but more than anything my friends stood
by my side when I think they visibly saw
me in so much pain and they didn't want
it for me but they sorry I
but speaking of collabs Taylor worked
with the contestants on the voice last
night she's the show's a mega mentor
this season and she had a little fun
with Blake Shelton oh my gosh yeah you
got yeah you might not scare on as a cat
that's one of the perks of being a cat
I'm here with Blake Lively and it's a
wonder oh it's not Blake Lively today I
also teamed up with Kelly Clarkson a
really good idea that you just made me
think of would it be cool to start on
the chorus yep like the drums hitting
different parts of it that I like you'll
always be added and I would not be
opposed to a Kelly Taylor collab IRL
these two totally support each other
Kelly of course had Taylor's back when
it came to her master recordings did you
see what you did you see the Taylor
Swift is now gonna rerecord for music
and it's because you suggested that it's
not what woman is the smartest business
woman I've ever seen in this industry
all right guys that's it for today for
all the latest on Taylor Selena and
Kelly keep it locked to all things et
until next time I'm Katie Krauss and bye
for now